good champagne yeah we don't skimp
around here where do you keep that yeah
Wow hey guys I'm Bryce ander this is
housewives happy hour and Dorinda and
Sonja are here the gals are here welcome
to LA Cheers
what's going on you're into the place I
can see it through the window
oh and down tonight it's like literally
nuthouse easy meals upstairs I gotta ask
how are we sitting here so cordial with
each other right now
it wasn't easy it was a brewing it was a
long time Abreu Ian I think since the
reunion so how would you describe this
fight that goes down Chloe has dumped
all this crap on me I was like where is
this coming from this diatribe of like
all these things about me that she was
collecting you had just been sitting
with it for months so it was well
bubbling by it's true I just put an easy
pass on that vagina with your Holly no
no explosive yes a clearing I'm telling
you it was a shock how did the room
react to horrified horrified everyone it
was a watershed moment
Tinsley was new to the whole thing
fortunes they want yeah that was I it's
kind of Tinsley's first housewives yeah
dinner party experience we connected
still and I have a weird kind of rub off
on her because you'll have my gosh I've
never seen people screaming at dinner
like oh she goes there
would you say your fight at this dinner
party is the biggest fight of the season
and if not who's it know who has the
biggest fight this season
drop it Bethenny in Milan oh it's a big
one I think it was incredibly upsetting
and I think it caused a real sad
unfortunate big break because it was
two-person I don't know I haven't really
did it was deep it wasn't a superficial
room misunderstanding
we're gonna cheers one more time thank
you guys for coming thank you for having
us that's Justin hi
[Music]
you